[Music]
welcome to episode 5 of the exit
strategy podcast I'm here with Paul
trend Paul you're the CEO and founder of
manscaped manscape you know native
started in 2015 manscape started around
then manscaped sells products that helps
men groom their groins is that right
that's that's whitespace and some of the
products that you sell just so people
have clarity are the lawnmower which
helps men trim their pubes deodorant for
your balls you know like a foot and a
foot odor product as well
what's the foot odor product called it's
called the flick duster it's called the
foot duster ok and you guys have a
really cheeky sense of humor you know
when people go into manscaped or look at
man escapes past you know I've read some
of your tag lines they're fantastic
one is I remember one cuz that's reading
it's called good sense when you trim the
hedges the tree stands taller who came
up with that I mean I mean that's true
right that's absolutely true who came up
with that tagline you know we have a
really talented marketing team you know
we're we're just you know it evolved as
I can't remember where exactly where
that where that tagline came from but
you know we just have a really talented
marketing team that that comes up with
these these really catchy sayings all
the time yeah that's certainly really
catchy you know one of the questions I
was thinking about when I was doing some
research about manscaped is how often
are men trimming their hedges do you
guys have any idea do you guys like
survey your customers about that kind of
information or what they do survey our
customers and it's it's actually it's
turned out to be much more frequent than
we thought a lot of men or you know of
course anything there's a bell curve
right there where the bell curve the
highest frequency is around once a week
to to once every 14 14
days so it's between you know seven and
14 days is when I wouldn't somebody
maintenance their Bush and what's uh
what's the other end of the bell curve
is the other end once every like five
years the the other end of course is you
know it follows it also follows the age
gap right when you're you're much older
less incentivize to do it so it's like
never right so the that's the other side
of the bell curve gotcha
yeah and that look um I guess who are
the who's buying who are buying these
products is it is it men who were like
hey I want to make myself look better
and my tree to stand taller or is it
women who are like I'm tired of looking
at my husband or boyfriend or partner's
looking like this
and so he needs to trim well we actually
have a pretty eclectic mix between men
and women during the holidays it's we
open marketing much much more to women
so we have more of more women customers
then you know the rest of the year but
really the truth is that if you if you
haven't groomed down there you don't
know what it feels like
I think if after you've done that you
feel it's it's refreshing so we've seen
that men like that actually start they
really enjoy it you know it's like it's
like you know we we got your hair is
really long you know and then then you
finally cut your hair it feels really
like it feels really relaxing we really
cool and and I think men start they're
starting to enjoy that you know it's it
feels fresher it's not as damn so I
think you start getting used to that
feeling and and becomes just a normal
thing yeah yeah your app your you're
right about a lot of that I know like
when I shave sometimes or at least get a
barber to cut my beard afterwards I just
feel like I'm a new human being and feel
great I don't know what it is about that
like I still don't understand what like
like what psychological impact that is
where I'm like okay this guy's just cut
my beer
it looks good but now I feel like I'm a
new I'm a newly reborn person yeah it's
it's and that's what we strive for you
know we I mean that's the essence of the
company at the end of the day at the end
of the day we just want you to feel
better you know like like the window we
think about it is life is pretty rough
already you know there's so much to do
there's so many responsibilities you
know we just want to make your life just
a little more enjoyable
yeah that's truly that's our mission
yeah and so there's a subscription
element to the business as well
aside from like I imagine like you the
the hero product that you guys have is
the lawn mower like what trimmed hedges
is that right absolutely so I mean if
you think about it we like to explain it
is that when you look at the female body
you realize you can start from head to
toe you're analyzing me you you realize
that there's a there's a product and a
brand for every single female care and
need you could dig up when you go to the
male body switch your attention to the
male body you start with you know inside
with your hood you got all you got your
Gillette your dog shows your up your
hair easily you go down to the Torsen is
not native you need that Old Spice when
you get down to the groin there's nobody
playing in the groin right there that is
total empty white space and you know we
got lucky and fortunate when we
recognized that you know three years ago
and we were able to capitalize on that
we were to obtain an amazing name so a
manscape you know right now I mean we
define the category of man sleeping
right so that manscape defines that
category and we just we totally own this
category and you know we and what's
really important for us is to create the
best products that we're the way that we
think about our mission and our mandate
is we we don't optimize for anything
other than quality so we're not we're
not optimizing for price we're not the
cheapest products we are the best
products so that that's that's kind of
how because there's just a lot of
products out there right I mean from
everything from the low end too high and
we want we want to focus on is creating
the absolute
best products and that's not until
non-mo of them it so talking about the
lawnmower which is like a trimmer for
your pubes really and a fantastic name
you know we'd love to delve more into
the name of manscaped and lawn mower in
a minute but like you know you're on the
lawn mower 3.0 what did like how did you
guys decide what went from lawn mower
2.0 to 3.0 and what what look what what
are you gonna put in lawn mower 4.0 look
is that a is that a you know it is there
customer feedback involved in that is
there look what's going on for you guys
to make those types of decisions
absolutely so we have a Facebook group
and I want to plug it here this is
Facebook
ballers group it's a VIP group and it's
invite-only you have to you know ask to
join but the deepest group is for our
closest best customers that are
interactive with us and when I say best
it's not on a monetary value how much
you buy it's just you know it's just
people that like the brand that want to
interact with with myself and our you
know our executive team and a product
development team and so we have about
close to 2 or 3,000 people in there that
are really interactive that they love to
test products so we have a great group
of core you know manscape fans sure can
do test new products but one of the
biggest things that we do is you know
our blade has what we called skin safe
technology and skin skin safe it makes
it really difficult for you to excuse my
friend should make your balls right
because if if you've ever nicked
yourself down there it is the most
horrible feeling you know that I think
that's what everyone is afraid of before
they start manscaping leads a lot you
know so our blades we it's the only
blade out there specifically engineered
to trim your groin this is not it's not
any other area of your face right like
in some of your beard it's pretty talked
your face is really easy to trim right
this is your loose skin with yeah
so it's not the same experience as as
trimming as trimming your beard it's
much more difficult so go back to your
TR to your question now how do we
determine the difference between the two
point on the three-point oh it's just
innovating you know in the product
pipeline your it might take like a year
18 months engineer and a great product
so we have multiple products lined up
that we're designing the 4.0 at the same
time we're designing the 5.0 and we're
putting it off into the 6.0 because
we're we're a hardware company in
addition to soft goods right so we have
our own Rd lab that we that we built out
that does all the soft grips all the
formulations you know the ball deodorant
and everything else that we're going to
get into but on a hardware side we have
our own in-house industrial designers
material experts and engineers that
design these and design and think
through the problems that you have so
when we when did we developed a 2.0 that
was really our first mass product with
skin-safe and then the 3.0 was an
evolution of the of the 2.0 you know it
had a light in there because you realize
like what even if you're a brat bathroom
is really lit your shadows you know so
like the light it seems we thought about
is it a gimmick you know if we put a
light but light on there what do we do
as a gimmick and then we actually put a
light on a prototype well this is
actually really useful because like you
you could because you need to see down
there you know like it's not the same
experience because you you know you
gotta see down there so putting the
light on there it was made it into the
3.0 the porn for porno I don't want to
talk about all the different features
but yeah we're really innovating on on
this experience and I don't we don't
think that there's many companies that
really looked at growing trimming and
how to innovate in that area well making
it safe easy and enjoyable and so going
back to this Facebook group are you
gonna like reach out to the Facebook
group and say hey guys we have the 4.0
does anyone want to try a couple samples
and give us your feedback before we
finalize this production is that how it
works or like an epoxy work that works
all the time so that why
that cycle there's much more frequent
with with our soft goods products so you
know all of our you know ball deodorant
and all the products that we're we're
testing in the pipeline now that is that
goes out that gets tested internally you
know goes all do all the stability
testing and and can all the employees
use it and then and then we expand it
out to our VIP ballers group and then
talk to me a little bit about R&D it's
really amazing that you can sort of have
that R&D in-house was an independent
company we never had that as native as
an independent company and even once we
joined Procter & Gamble like we did some
R&D internally but most of the R&D we
did like with their party manufacturers
how big is this R&D group I haven't
heard of like a start-up sort of
thinking about R&D or like you know
early on or within the first five years
of their existence like you guys are
doing how big is that R&D group so that
goes back to a firm belief of mine you
know I've always kind of thought I
always I always thought it was really
important not only to go wide but also
go deep and what that means is you got a
you got to know you know a lot of
different things but you just can't you
just can't be a what was theirs there's
a saying was saying you know a
jack-of-all-trades with master of none I
don't think an entrepreneur can be like
that
I think anon to be to be really
successful you not only have to go wide
we you also have to go deep and you've
got to be a master a lot of things so
yeah with that with with that that
belief now we always we we made sure
that everything was done in-house if
we've never hired an agency and we don't
use any agencies for anything all video
production is done in-house all media
buying is done in-house R&D is done
in-house oh my god there's no agencies
how's it look the the technology that
you guys build out you guys have your
own developers when you guys launch a TV
commercial
you have your own in-house production
agency make it you have your own
in-house creative agency decide what it
is and then your own in-house like
agency or your own in-house employees
cut it up as well
an edit yeah that's it how big is the
entire team then right now we're seeing
about 72 employees okay yeah that is not
that big and pretty amazing based on
like the amount of content that I see
coming out of manscaped so you guys are
certainly productive at creating content
and when did you guys hire your first
R&D employee then well I mean just like
many other startups in the CPG space you
know we we use contract manufacturers so
we use a third party lab to create our
first products but I think it's about
about a year five 14 months ago when we
started really building out our own R&D
lab Wow and hire the first already our
new research chemist and you know it was
we knew that we had to retain this
knowledge and really understand it you
know from top down so having it in-house
we've got to iterate very quickly and we
didn't like this let's change it and so
we're like what would take you know what
would take weeks from from from we're
working with a lab cuz you know we work
with labs before you got to send them to
them you know send them a brief they
send you samples chirpin and you saw
them back and forth it just yeah the
cycles are just way too long
right so for us having a team that we
can work with hand-in-hand
is it was was just really accelerated
that gotcha
okay let's start talking a little bit
more about like the early days of
manscaped so before this rnt R&D team
exists before you guys are sort of
developing a lot more 4.0 you know you
guys were working on the original
products manscape gets on Shark Tank at
some point and it's some like uh you
know you're on Shark Tank you're working
on the original marketing for the for
that for the company is do you guys call
the first do collies call the first
product you release a lawnmower 1.0 and
we stopped the lawnmower yeah it was
cold okay gotcha yeah and look how do
you guys yeah tell me a little bit more
about how this marketing strategy
developed because certainly like you
know I I think everyone is familiar with
the Dollar Shave Club like
like commercial or video initial video
that really launched that brand and how
spectacularly successful it was you know
how Michael do been saying you don't
need Roger Federer to endorse your razor
blade why are you paying Roger Federer
to shave how did you guys get started in
terms of your marketing strategy so you
know we first started to be we knew that
this is something that was good for men
way it helped with being you know it's
hygienic and its cleanliness right yeah
so we started off with messaging in that
way like dudes you guys should do this
because it's good for you you'll feel
better and none of that one about
resonating right how long did you try
that type of marketing for there was
like more serious and less cheeky
probably for three months okay and how
much money did you have to spend in
those three months to be like this isn't
working out
it's a ballpark it what is it $10,000 or
$100,000 I think we spent five fifty
thousand dollars
I'm market okay realize that that didn't
work and then yeah then tell me about
the evolution then what happened yeah so
then you know being scientific no it
just didn't gravitate to anyone you know
so then weeds and we just we basically
change gears you know we knew that there
was a market for this there was white
space we knew that we had we had to
crack it and figure out how to
communicate with men because
communicating like in my past I've I've
had startups that focused primarily on
women in skin care right and and
perfumes and colognes and you know even
in SAS and other things right but but we
needed to understand that we have to get
to that tipping point of understanding
how to communicate with men in this way
and we realized that you know dudes
aren't talking about this like don't
stand around the water cooler and be
like hey you look so great today what
you use all of my volumizer like kind of
condition using dudes don't do that
right yeah they don't talk about
skincare they don't talk about
deodorants or hygiene right
but they'll talk about funny things
right things that were hilarious that
that entertains him so then we started
creating our first video I remember was
a video because it was towards the end
of the year and we had produced this
video of Santa Claus trimming so it was
in it was it was in an apartment and
Ryan Fiore our vp of marketing was the
one that actually dressed up as Santa
and he's got his Santa pants down on his
ankles and the camera is just panning
and it looks like snow falling down
right and then as you pan Santa's legs
snowing you here there's like buzzing
sound it's kind of snowing indoors
because it was I didn't inside inside on
the house
so as you're you know and then we had
another person was like Katherine was
was sprinkling you know these fake white
hairs on onto the ground and we were we
were pulling back the camera that was
panning back and panning out and you can
see Santa's legs so that was the that
was kind of the first video that we that
we shot that was the first time you
moved from like was that the first like
move you had towards the cheeky sense of
humor from being serious about like hey
this is good for you it's gonna make you
feel better yeah that was that was the
first one okay let me talk a little bit
more about the 50,000 you spent where
that didn't work well where did you end
up spending that 50,000 over those like
three months to be like let's test to
see if this you know if this concept has
any legs because you know you have a
product that you know consumers want
you're trying to find out the right
marketing channels and the right
marketing you know messaging to go out
with that that marketing messaging is
what's failing where did you spend that
fifty thousand dollars but I think I
think this answer is gonna be kind of
defacto answer across many many startups
you spending on chase looking we spend
out of Google and any that is just the
reality
yeah whatever but what I do want to say
about that is like all you entrepreneurs
out there don't don't get a false sense
of confidence that you are your cap is
so low even that you're you're doing so
well on Facebook that this is going to
scale infinitely you know could you
start winning those numbers right you're
like on Facebook like oh man my cap it's
20 bucks if I if I dump you know 200
million dollars into marketing I
wouldn't make this much yes there
doesn't work out it doesn't work that
way there is a Facebook and a Google
wall and I'll use it didn't different
Facebook ceiling you're gonna hit that
ceiling and it's gonna hurt and a lot of
a lot of entrepreneurs need to realize
that early on we will work really
fortunate that we realize that early on
because you gotta think about it
Facebook is really really good at
targeting I mean Facebook and Google
these guys are data powerhouses they
know how to target and find the right
buyers for you but there's if you are if
you are market you have your total
addressable market is this big Yeah
right
you're gonna hit that ceiling pretty
quickly you know so you have to really
think about how to broaden your product
appeal and into to make sure that you
are addressing a very large total
addressable market in your addressable
market like eventually you're gonna have
to market to men or women or both if
you're still doing like fine-tuned
targeting you know love your lights and
you can extract every value you can't
steal it I think that look I what you
said definitely has a ton of is
absolutely correct like at native you
know we saw a $2 CAC in 2015 a $4 CAC in
2016 a 650 CAC in 2017 so one even
looking at that $2 CAC it basically more
than tripled over the course of two
years but and we saw those like there
were multiple ceilings we got to there
was a ceiling at $200,000 there was a
ceiling at $500,000 there was a much
denser ceiling at $1,000,000 and trying
to push against the ceilings took a lot
of time and a lot of effort and a lot of
like right messaging and you're
absolutely right from an odd
targeting perspective as well look
look-alike audiences absolutely crushed
it for us for a really long period of
time until we hit one of those ceilings
like you know we use the look-alike
audience of 1% which look like you know
2 million people and then you know you
start expanding that to 2% and 3% and
then all of a sudden look-alikes don't
work anymore and then you at some point
you're just like I'm targeting all women
and then I feel like I'm targeting all
humans that exist on earth now you can
reality like not everyone is gonna buy
something when they see a Facebook ad
right like you know Facebook does a
great job of segmenting their audiences
they're like you know they have let's
say theirs they have 300 million people
in the United States something like 80%
of the people that are on Facebook
generally won't click ads and make a
purchase from it and so everybody is
competing for those 20% of people who do
buy things online and so you're a judge
even if your total addressable market
it's this big in reality online it's
this big because you know there's just
fewer people buying things that are
online absolutely absolutely you got to
get to if you want to build a truly
scalable business you gotta eventually
figure out how to get off of platforms
you gotta be if you don't get off of
online I mean online should it's always
a part of your marketing mix and your
marketing strategy right but it should
never be a hundred percent like as soon
as you can you know you gotta you're
gonna go through withdrawal symptoms of
getting off platforms but you can start
diversifying your your marketing or it's
just never going to scale
everywhere now we we have figured out
how to and this is where we're very
fortunate we have a really talented
marketing team you know but we thought
off of Facebook and Google probably last
year I went what is it off I mean we
diversify from it yeah one of the one of
our big channels is still is still
YouTube right because a lot of people
spend their time there where one of the
biggest spenders on Hulu where we have a
massive TV budget UFC sponsorship I mean
we spawned to the UFC where we haven't
really announced it yet but we're gonna
be one of the exclusive sponsors of the
San Francisco 49ers
you know so what does that mean if
you're an exclusive sponsor for the
49ers what does that mean that means
that I think that next year when you go
to the
by CEM and you go into any of the
bathrooms you're gonna see all our
signage on top of all the urinals that's
gonna be I mean the great thing is
that's what we those some things we crap
right it's like yeah how many how many
companies out there can actually buy
that bad the ad unit right likely who's
gonna buy the ad unit mcapples not gonna
buy that you know sheriff or urinal
right but it fits so well for us and it
fits our cheeky toned that it that it
works for us right so like what are you
doing right there you you're like you
you're thinking about it right so you
know when we had when you see analysis
as a finger point down with the children
says got Bush you're like you're
standing right there you can find a
evaluate and think about that okay I
want to talk much more about this I want
to talk a little bit about the past as
well but before we get off this topic
how much get you ballpark the cost to me
for San Francisco 49ers sponsorship is
that six figures or seven figures five
figures oh yeah I know it's I I can't
imagine it's five figures so give me a
ballpark because you know like let me
give you a couple examples you know we
interviewed Kara from hint water yeah
like a couple weeks ago and she told she
told me how she bought a Superbowl
commercial for under 1 million dollars
we interviewed Andrew who's the CEO of
this company called hymns which is like
a you know men's sexual wellness company
and he bought urinals over the you know
over giant stadium give me an idea of
what like just ballpark the cost for me
you don't need to give me the exact
number is it high six figures low six
figures mid six figures is it seven
figures give me some you know at native
we were running you know a very lean
budget but by the end it but by the time
we were you know doing over a hundred
million dollars we had a pretty sizable
marketing budget we were spending money
on TV ads on Billboard's in New York
City we spent we're gonna spend a
million dollars in 2020 or we were going
to before covet really aunt on bill I'm
sorry on subway ads in New York City in
2020 and you know that included like
station takeovers which cost like a low
very low six figures and that included
some you know photos and subway trains
would cost like about forty thousand
dollars what is a forty niners exclusive
spa
ship getchu are you gonna go are you
gonna do you have a booth are you gonna
go to games and give me the price or
give me a ball you know it's it's in the
six figures not not to the seven figures
yeah but definitely in the six figures
okay and does it include a bunch of
tickets or am I gonna see you at a bunch
of 49ers games yeah I mean 49ers are
just a phenomenal team management wise
they're so awesome we got to go to the
Super Bowl with them we with NFC
playoffs in you know in their box it was
okay let's go let's rewind a little bit
and go back to the Santa Clause
commercial so you guys have you know
it's been three months the seriousness
it wasn't working we were spending on
Facebook and Google burn fifty thousand
dollars didn't love what happened you've
sort of pivoted now you're running this
Santa Claus commercial or like you
you've got the Santa Claus video what do
you do with it yeah like you know it's
really funny it's cheeky super
interesting but it's kind of relevant
cuz it's winter nobody's ever heard of
Santa Claus trimming his pubes but
that's really funny what happened what
do you do with that commercial and when
do you realize that cheeky sense of
humor makes sense so I would I would
answer that in two parts so the first
the first part is you once again you run
it on Facebook and Google right that's
that's the first thing so you so you run
it on you run it on Facebook or you read
on YouTube and what you're tracking for
at that time is that how am i how much
on my pain / CPM and per click right now
what am i what am i where's it cost me
they deliver traffic to the website yeah
right and then and then when they get to
the website then you've been now you're
you're you know you have to make sure
that you're really observant and
performing a lot of conversion rate
optimization right you've got to make
sure that you're you're that lead closes
when they get to the site where you
present them with the right offer
so the first part of only answer your
question is you know we've got that
video we're testing we're running it on
on Facebook running it on YouTube and
we're tracking how much it's costing us
remember at that time we weren't broad
yet we're still like okay we're gonna
we're gonna advertise to men
that's 18 - you know 25 it's gonna run
this video with this call to action and
then there's then we're running 35 to 40
with this video or this cut different
call to action and then it's all gonna
drive to the website so then you know of
course you're calculating what are my
CPM is what are my CPAs and more
important my cpc's and then when they
get to the site that's when you really
start doing a lot of work with like
offer testing like what do I need to
offer what do we need to say because
early days really really early days when
you what you're looking for is when
you're looking for our signals right and
you have to be really in tune with your
entire marketing strategy to understand
these signals right and what I mean by
signals is early on I sort of bleep
three pillars of what what is important
to our male audience and this is very
early on right it was you know when when
you trim the bush the tree stands taller
right that was that was an important
motivation factor for them yeah right
use the right tools for the job right so
if you gonna do this
don't hurt yourself because like that
that was a really important marketing
message that really got them that really
got me to understand it so we could we
distilled down you know this really big
concept of hey guys don't cut yourself
because that's crude to say right so it
really just became if you know use the
right tools in the job right so what
would you trim the hedges the cheese
stands taller it tells you okay well
then that that works right you kind of
equate then you kind of understand that
there's a there's a benefit right
outside of you just feeling good because
for us we we knew that ultimately we
wanted to be a much bigger brand of
encompasses you know masculinity and
empowerment for men we didn't want to
just be a growing a growing business
that was that was never that was never
our intention we wanted to empower men
but to get there we had to figure out
what what what we what men were
receptive to right so that's where that
you know if you trim the bushes the tree
stands taller men got that right away
wait you've got they got why they should
do that and
how they were and we see this power it's
not receive this feeling of empowerment
right and then after that it was author
was all I used to write or some job
because you don't don't cut yourself
don't hurt yourself that was that was
the that was the big learning that that
cost probably two hundred thousand
quarter of a million to really learn and
it's it's really kind of philosophical
when you're talking about marketing in
this way you know what like to spend
that much money just to learn these two
key things and most people like a lot of
people like there are not marketers
they're not they're not really in tune
with with their audience that might just
pass them oh they really get that but we
tested a lot of marketing message and
realize that that those two things
combined together really resonated
really got meant to understand why you
should do this the need and why you
should use dedicated tools that we
created to solve this problem so I think
any any startup Eddie any started trying
to build a brand and not just a Fastpass
forum where you're just selling utility
right you're satisfied when you sell
utility this you know we solve your
problem like this right what you really
build a brand in a CPG a highly
competitive CPG space you have to
distill your marketing message to be so
fine-tune that that it really resonates
with a broad audience
so you tested can you give me examples
of so the two that worked were you know
tree stands taller use the right tools
bird in the job what were some of the
marketing messages you thought might
work and ended up not working do you
remember any of those there was so many
we we had like we had a bunch that that
was it was a 10 on that made it to the
shortlist of you know it was a you know
you know fueled fuel fresher or
something like that right it was was one
of them you know you know make sure
you're clean and ready all the time and
it was it was a bunch of different
along that vein but it just didn't
resonate you know it was just it it just
didn't click with with dudes and and
that's what you're searching for us as
marketers trying to market any product
that's what you're searching for you're
searching for
though that with this how to sell your
product in one simple statement to
understand your audience understands it
and sees the mead instantly yeah so you
spend $200,000 sort of testing that
messaging on Facebook and Google you
know yeah I really liked what you said
earlier which was once you get people to
your website you have to like optimize
offers as well
I feel like too often people are like
great what is my CPA and my CPA is what
I was like how good is my face but God
and what they don't look at is how good
is my landing page am i convincing
people once they get to my landing page
that they should buy this product that
it's a good value and that they should
buy it now and not two weeks from now
and I feel like they're you know those
are two sides of the same coin and both
are gonna dramatically impact CPA right
like you can say hey tree stands taller
on your facebook ad and like you know
the flip side of that coin the landing
page can be used the right tools for the
job but if the landing page it's like
buy this trimmer because you know your
balls aren't the same as your face it
could be a very different type of CPA
yeah I did a lot of entrepreneurs and
it's that see that that's that's where I
go back to you know it's it's difficult
to it's difficult to hire an agency
unless you got a lot of a lot of money
right you know your venture funded and
that you know we weren't at that time
you know and so it wasn't unless we had
a lot of money you wouldn't be able to
buy enough time of an agency to actually
come up with these things you know - so
if you if you're an entrepreneur and you
could give a really phenomenal product
you spent years building this product I
I would say take that take that leap
don't be shy because I in my core at the
half of my career I was technologist
like I I didn't I didn't do CPG you know
I wasn't I wasn't a brand and guy there
wasn't a marketer I was I was a
technology so I built SAS
and software so I would say that don't
be shy take that risk and and do the
marketing yourself because you're the
only one that really understands the
value of your product like to try to
communicate that with an agency and it's
it's gonna it's gonna it it's really
really hit or miss unless you've got a
lot of money and you're and you're
paying for a lot of their time it just
it just I have seen it not work out very
well couldn't agree more
when we were when native was growing the
entire time we were an independent
company I ran all paid ads after we sold
the business I still ran paid ads until
probably like six months ago or
something to that effect or like you
know maybe eight months ago at this
point because I was just like this is
the backbone of the business this is how
we're growing this is one of the reasons
we're growing very quickly and I don't
want to outsource that to somebody else
who you know by necessity like you know
is is an agency by definition and there
will be agency costs as a result of that
they won't care as much they don't care
about the business they won't be looking
at the metrics as quickly as I am or as
frequently as I am and they won't be
iterating on different tests on messages
like if this is a skill that I have if
this is a skill that's important to the
company I should get good at this skill
or I should least understand this skill
and so like you know one of the things
that you mentioned was you need a lot of
money in order to hire these agencies in
order like you know to get them to do
good work going back to what you guys
did you guys spent fifty thousand
dollars and it didn't really work out
with the serious messaging two hundred
thousand dollars and you realized what
messaging did work how were you were
able to afford this stuff because early
on you were bootstrapped
yeah I mean we were bootstrap for and we
grew organically for a very very long
time and how we know it would do through
prior successes you know you gotta you
know you gotta gamble and and reinvest
you know that's the I would think that's
the best way to to talk about and you
know fundraising and and and spending
investor dollars it has its it has its
price there's there's a there's a cost
to that right and I think I think very
often that gets OH
shadowed by the glitz and glamour of
fundraising and closing around and
that's where I would I would advise
entrepreneurs that you know closing
because right now when you read the news
right
every closes around and everyone's
cheering there's a lot of PR around it
like dude that's just the beginning and
you don't know how much less and that's
what's gonna be on your ass all the time
you know how to spend that money and
then you get into a point where you're
starting to spend frivolously you know
it's like I guarantee you we had a
million dollars in the bank we would
have spent about $200,000 would have
spent half a million tested yeah right
you so I think it's it's a silikal trap
to raise money way too early because
number one that's when you lose the most
amount of the most of your company right
it's early on mom most amount of
dilution you look back like oh my god
that was crazy right looking within like
it makes you it makes you not as strict
with with yourself and with your budget
absolutely I couldn't agree more with
all that you know we raised like fifty
thousand dollars and it was a great sign
that we were onto a successful business
we raised that native we raised $50,000
and like a five million dollar valuation
probably four months into the business
and then another 250 K maybe within the
first year and those were you know the
reason that I did that early on the
business was working I wasn't like in
reality we didn't even need that 250k I
was just like I want to make sure that
there's external validation that what
I'm doing here is right I think that was
the primary reason and the secondary
reason was that I was like I'm in San
Francisco and this is what everyone here
does everyone raises money as a sign of
success there's this great tweet I saw I
don't remember who tweeted it and
someone's like raise 10 million dollars
and you get invited to every party in
San Francisco sell your business and
make 10 million dollars crickets like
people somehow celebrate the fundraising
more than they do actually the
successful exits which doesn't make any
sense well look what scale were you at
when you did raise your first few checks
and you know I want to make sure there's
some disclosure here I was one of those
Jax at some point what scale were you at
when you raised his first few checks
well this first few checks we I mean we
were we were beyond eight figures wait
wait well by the time we raised those
those first few checks would you say you
were beyond eight figures you mean you
were like north of ten million dollars
not north of a hundred million dollars
correct okay yeah and those in those few
checks the you know the impetus behind
those was to bring on talent at yourself
right I mean we we called it a a
sweetheart round or a sweetheart note
because we wanted to bring on amazing
talent so there weren't any B C's in in
that note it was it was everyone that
was pretty much hand selected from a
group of friends you know select like
yourself like Nick from thrive and like
from this amazing individuals that could
really contribute to to the business
that can have the experience and we
wanted to actually call and talk to you
you know I will call I'll call you when
you're in China and we'll talk about
that was the that was the reason why we
need and has that been helpful
you know we raise money we raise five
hundred thousand dollars at native about
half the investors I would say we're
really helpful like people that I could
call and be like hey this is a problem
I'm having have you had it before you
know we like Nick was the first episode
of this podcast he actually helped me
with a bunch of trademarks top or at
least made me think about trademark
stuff early on there were there was a
one of our investors was an executive of
Facebook who's really helpful and
helping us just get access to the right
people at Facebook that we needed
another was just like a calming voice
who you know was a VC and it sort of
seen a bunch of things happen in San
Francisco and so was like when I called
him up he's like his name's Paul Ferris
from Azure and he's like hey boys this
is how to think about things you're
panicking too much have the investors
that you sort of let in those sweet
hearts have those sweet hearts been
helpful
I was absolutely and I think you you
nailed it on the head
with about 50% it's like about even even
when you hand select these guys yes
group of investors everyone's got their
own lives or everyone has to focus so
everyone you hand select only 50% will
be really valuable so imagine if you
don't hand select them and it's just a
group of a bunch of different people are
you the value out of that will be
dramatically lower right so yeah 50% I
can call anytime and and I want to say
there's you gotta manage expectations
right everyone step their own lives
I mean suck their own jobs but just
invest in your company doesn't mean that
you have you know ten hours a week of
their time you gotta manage expectations
right so it's really key decisions hey
I'm going through this what do you think
you know you don't need manufacturers in
here or whatever whatever it's a set up
brought email and you know hey anybody
can help me with connecting with this
person that person that's what you can
get really rapid responses and they can
be really helpful yeah okay let's do a
little bit of fast forwarding you've
raised this money from a bunch of
sweethearts including myself
you've spent two hundred two hundred
fifty thousand dollars on Facebook and
Google with the Santa Claus commercial
and you're like okay I'm not gonna talk
about anything I'm not gonna be I'm
gonna be less serious and be more cheeky
with my humor because that's what's
resonating with consumers at what point
you start getting off Facebook and
Google look you know I think the most
one of the most impressive things I
found about manscaped is the diversity
of channel acquisition like YouTube is a
really hard channel for people to scale
so lucky you know Hulu we've tried on
Hulu like what native has been on Hulu
ads wasn't nearly as successful as you
guys how do you guys test how do you
guys well first first help me understand
your largest channels of customer
acquisition is it YouTube is it still
Facebook like what is the largest
Channel still well it depends I mean
Facebook and Google is still a very
large channel and in between I mean
between YouTube between do YouTube
Google and and Facebook is a large
channel right because Facebook
encompasses both of their assets with
this Facebook and Instagram is very very
large channel because can't forget about
Instagram everyone talks about Facebook
sure but it's getting a huge
channel so that's where a lot of spend
goes the other spend is on on Google of
course there's Adwords right there in
CDN there is so many different ad units
and you guys are the most you know
startup on tourists I've even haven't
even considered right on on the Google
platform and then there's YouTube which
drives a tremendous amount of traffic
and that's I should say tremendous
amounts of views not necessarily
attractive okay because there's so much
inventory on YouTube it's just it's so
hard to crack like YouTube is so hard to
crack okay let me ask you in a different
way if you had to choose if all of these
channels were gonna be regulated by the
FTC and all of them were gonna be shut
down except one which one would you want
to continue to exist it depends on when
right now I would say Google today yeah
you'd say 182 which today what Google
okay and then help you understand a
little bit more about YouTube are you
guys doing pre-roll ads or Road you guys
doing like influence or based ads on
YouTube we're doing hero ads where do
influence your ads we're doing
user-generated content we're doing I
mean we signed we have a a team of five
in our influencer department and all
they do is work with influencers so it
gets to a point where you have to keep
grinding and there's a tipping point
where you're like everything starts to
gel because all these channels lift
everything right like you can't you
can't just be on Facebook and be
successful you gotta be on Facebook on
Google and Hulu on everything else to
actually to actually scale massively so
we realize that on very very early on so
this year is a big push for us to kind
of be be me everywhere including
billboards that we don't like we got 20
billboards out there now you know you're
in ads and you have sea-fight so we're
on the Conor McGregor fight but a car in
NASCAR Wow yeah so tell me how you
structure your team to handle all that
do you guys have like is is one person
that's working on YouTube also working
on Instagram or is there somebody who's
dedicated to YouTube somebody who's
dedicated to UFC fights and somebody
who's dedicated to NASCAR so there there
is there's an out-of-home director joey
Kovac he's this phenomenal and you
really I think the way that is it to
answer your first part your question is
how do you structure you gotta find the
best people the best people will bring
in the best people will bring in the
best people you know so it's so
important as as an entrepreneur to to
build the team right when you're the one
of your primary jobs as a CEO is to
build the team right to lead the vision
and build team so bringing in your your
the right generals the right key people
in that leadership team will
automatically start to bring in the
right people on the next layer right
yeah so you know Ryan and I have been
working together Ryan as a VP of
Marketing has been working together for
almost a decade now he brought in Joey
Kovac which is phenomenal Joey you know
work did a lot of the marketing for
movement before they exited from from
the ground up then he brought in Nate
singer the two to him to handle Google
and YouTube and then we brought in
Nathalie hopin to handle radio so and
then she was phenomenal
she got us on Howard Stern and all these
you know all these amazing podcasts and
then and then they brought in Lauren on
the markings and and Lauren does all of
influencers about the influencer routine
so it sounds like you have directors for
each channel though as opposed like you
know you have a YouTube to somebody who
manages YouTube somebody who manages
out-of-home somebody manages Instagram
and yes and that sort of structured it
under a VP of Marketing correct and then
however for start-up though well for
start-up oh I don't want to I don't want
you to think that that's how that's what
you need to start right you don't need
that to start you got to do everything
wrong right yeah in the beginning like
Ryan and I were
on YouTube every single day like
clicking through refreshing like a
thousand times a day to see metrics
right that's how you start and then when
you would you reach critical mass that's
when you bring in someone to handle well
you go on and you pioneer the next
channel yeah I think that's a great
thing to mention like I feel like a lot
of people want to be like want to be in
seven different marketing channels when
they launch their business and it's hard
to be an expert you know I've rarely met
people who are good at Facebook and
Google Ads
and people are like yeah I'm gonna try
and run Facebook Google snap Pinterest
and tik-tok ads when I launch my
business and I'm like you're not gonna
be able to measure look you're gonna
forget everything that you've ever done
by the time you're looking at tik-tok
ads you know which is your fifth Channel
today you're gonna forget what your
Facebook ads look like and so it's
really hard to be a master of so many
channels right out of the gate you know
I'm a big fan of sort of going deep on
one or two channels or three if you are
able to and becoming a master of those
and then hiring people once you're sort
of able to once you understand the
metrics behind those and you've built
some sort of critical mass and know how
to look you you know you understand the
next three to four months of the
trajectory of that channel you gotta
master you got a message where you move
on yeah absolutely and then how do you
think about budgets when you're doing
this so is there like a quarterly
meeting for budgets or an annual meeting
for budgets where you're like okay
influencer team you get 12 percent of
our budget radio team you get 10 percent
of our budget how do you guys think
order or you look sort of like you know
what influencers we're willing to spend
up to $30.00 tax spend as much as you
can until you had $30 you know how do
you think about that I mean now we are I
mean to be to be honest now we are right
like we're we're much more systematic
now we're much more organized but the
first two years let's be honest nobody's
getting six budgets in the first two
years you're still learning so much
you're still growing so much and it's
still so fluid that like you know do we
just we just launch this channel with
this video the the CPA is so well kind
of go balls out right yeah and that's
the only thing that matters over the
question is this chill everyone else be
quiet this is the channel that can make
a business now I want to make sure that
the listeners are and
the entrepreneurs out there don't get a
you know don't think that you need to
have budgets in place on that you know
in the early days you just kind of make
it work that's all you gotta do you
gotta make it work that's all you gotta
focus on yeah in the early days it's
always audibles right like every day is
a new fire that you have to put out and
the rare days where you don't have fires
that can sort of focus on marketing
channels you got to go with just what's
working and not like a not dogma you
can't be like you know what Facebook
were or like you know YouTube worked for
Paul at manscaped I'm gonna spend money
on you know people come up to me in
there like hey Facebook work for you
guys I get Facebook to work for me and
I'm like look Facebook work for us it's
like you know it will work for us it
almost certainly will not work for you
we had a specific use case you know we
were on there a different time than
Facebook is today and like you know we
were spending a lot of resources on
Facebook for you guys the content that
you have and the cheeky humor is much
more amenable to video than it maybe
tillich a quick mobile uh you know photo
and so it's just a different channel
that works and like people cannot get a
caught up on the dogma of others they
have to call audibles when they get to
the line see what's working and spend
their time and resources there
absolutely what did you guys like um
fail at so like you know certainly you
it sounds you know and maybe they said
that maybe fails a bad word you know at
native we fail that a ton of stuff
operations for a really long time until
we hired a stellar operations person
finance forever what did you guys feel
that like you know it certainly the like
not doing the cheeky marketing was tough
did you guys have operational supply
issues because these things can't be
easy to it's not like you
you know um with deodorant you want to
make more you probably can do it in
there and like you know a week like you
need a week of heads up maybe two weeks
these are you know hardware components
that cannot be made in a day or two days
it's not mixing ingredients together I
mean some of your products are but a lot
of them aren't you know what were the
things that you guys struggled with to
make the business a success
absolutely right so I mean kind of an
all-encompassing way if you if you're in
software and SAS then you don't have to
worry about you know making stuff right
you know you got to worry about them
having enough servers but now there's
clouds and but we have to worry about
that anymore either
right so that's why software is so can
be so lucrative
if you get the right win but but for
hard and physical products and
operations supply chain you know it it's
it's a lot of work so I'm exactly with
you like we failed in Opera and
operations if we failed multiple times
of operations meaning what was one of
the example of a disaster you guys had
disaster so were like one of the things
that you fail that in operations
specifically yeah so we had we were on a
run rate we had projected inventory for
the entire q1 right we bought it we have
it in stock it was November we're like
we're good and we bought so much
inventory or like we're good for the
next quarter
this is November and we're like when
we're good until we're good until April
and that's that's how much inventory we
had by December 16th and so but so now
all inventory and we're like oh crap it
was it was easy you're like everyone and
our families were in the warehouse
packing new like new inventory to send
out so that was definitely failure so we
we shipped late to our customers which
means they weren't happy with us that
means that's a fail for us that we
wanted to light our customers all the
time and you know that really that bad
sucked and that doesn't go away by the
way like that that happens all the time
all the time like when you're scaling
you can never predict how like Howard
Stern would do would do a you know a
read things what things would just pop
and you know influencers would do would
launch their videos things will just pop
and which is it's just really difficult
to manage all the channels because now
we were only channel right so we're not
just a subscription OTT just a b2c
company where we've got Amazon we like D
to see without international and without
retail so now we're working with you
know a lot of all our retail partners
and your your planning with them months
and months that he tells a different
beast it's not need to see you're
planning a year in advance
time's yeah I think I uh I didn't
understand how hard it would be until
Native got into retail like you know we
scaled we have the same opera problems
you did in terms of like running out of
inventory in 2015 we were making 500
units of deodorant a week by 2017 we
were making 21,000 units a day and we
were still like selling out like you
know if you bought your deodorant on a
Thursday it was either made the day
before the day after it was like it's
not like we had a lot of inventory but
once you sell it to Target and Walmart
and like large brick-and-mortar stores
you know their first order could be you
know five 300,000 units or 2050 thousand
units and all of a sudden the
just-in-time inventory that you had
always been reliant on is no longer
sustainable yeah absolutely it looks it
gets really difficult as ask your SKU
starts to expand also yeah yeah so tell
me about some of the retailers you
gathering you guys are in target today
any other retailers
we're in Target Best Buy and we're
looking to focus on Target and Best Buy
because I had we feel that that's where
our audience lives you know we have a
lot of great retail partners but we're
gonna for the time being at least for
2020 we're really gonna focus on
targeting this way and is does your
online site make up the majority of your
sales or do Target and Best Buy make up
the majority of your sales no d2c web
ecommerce makes up the majority of our
sales and is there like cyclic allottee
to the business you know it's really
interesting that you said by December
16th you've sort of sold out I've
imagined that people are buying this
product for Christmas
is there another bump in sales for
instance right before Valentine's Day
you know Valentine's Day Father's Day
any gift-giving holiday we see a bug
yeah because that's when women bias
gifts for men and then of course
holidays that's when we women really buy
as gifts for men but then yeah men are
also spending on themselves so q4 is
definitely huge just any other
e-commerce keyboard to you to everybody
yeah well I mean the q4 is he's like for
Native it was actually probably one of
the worst corners in part because like
deer you tend to wear more dealer in the
summer when it's hot
out as opposed to the winter when it's
cold out and you know some people give
deodorants gifts in fact a lot of people
do a lot more than I suspected but like
you know if I gave you a tea odor and
it's a gift I think you'd be like well
this is nice but like okay this is like
a pretty mediocre gift I mean if I gave
you a package of manscaped it'd be very
different from like you know it's it's
obviously higher price point and a great
like on a much nicer gift
I wonder if men ever accuse like men who
get this as a gift from their female
partners I wonder if they ever accuse
them of being like this is a gift for
yourself like when I buy lingerie for
you to gift for me this is a gift for
yourself I don't you know one folder we
haven't polled our customers thought
that that might be the case but we have
a lot of you know unboxing experience
that people unboxing reactions on
Instagram and tik-tok it's been pretty
yeah did you work your way up when it
came to influence their advertising did
you start it like micro influencers and
work your way up to like you know a list
celebrities or were you like you know
what let's go big right out of the gate
and get the Kim Kardashian's or Tom
Brady's of the world to try this product
you know we still haven't gone with
celebrities and we have not kept an
image to that region so we're we're
talking but he went we went with amazing
influencers so what a first influencer
that we have abroad on was jose zuniga
of teaching men's fashion he's
phenomenal the dude is dude knows his
stuff he's you know yes he really knows
men's hygiene and grooming and so we
tapped him as one of our first
influencers and we still work very
closely with him today so I guess like
with your budget right away going after
maybe the celebrity is a bad example was
your budget right away sort of saying
hey let's put ten thousand or fifty
thousand or a hundred thousand dollars
to test among different influencers to
see what works and what doesn't or would
you look I'm ready to go with an
influencer that has five hundred
thousand people that may not be an
a-list celebrity but certainly a large
Instagram so you know but I think I'm
you're gonna test it influence your
market testing micro influencers will
give you a really bad data because it
just there's not enough reach right yeah
you got it
you gotta test with enough reach to have
its active sampler I thought the more
data you have the better the better the
results the better David you better the
better you can conclude on your data
right so you know I think I think at
that time Jose had like four million
followers or on YouTube and that was
that was the that was the right amount
for us to really do a good test Wow
all right so you're looking for guys who
already like rather large on YouTube but
before you spend money there is that
still the case are you still sort of
focusing on those people that have the
million-plus or are you willing to go
down now to people who have 10,000 plus
four subscribers now it's now our our
influencer team evaluates each influence
of potential influence a partner and
then we evaluate for primarily is
authenticity like if you if you've got
30,000 followers or 30,000 fans or
whatever that is you know on each on
these different platforms and in your
Instagram all you're doing is pushing
product you're not the right influencer
for us yeah you know we want you to
actually test our product you know
really use it and be a fan of it right
because that authenticity comes out
because we as a brand really value or
authenticity we want to have a really
authentic voice and that's that's really
important to our brand and so how do
female influencers sort of project that
authenticity is it sort of talking about
you know their partners or how do female
you know users project that authenticity
well it it depends
usually it's the way that they the way
that they do is they it depends on which
platform right so on on Instagram we're
just taking pictures of it and or
something and many times are taking
pictures with a partner as like you guys
because Instagram is a very photo based
platform whereas on YouTube it's mostly
couples it's the if it's if it's a a
woman Instagram or a female Instagram
they would be they would pair up with
their partner right and and talk about
the product because there's so many ways
you can talk about this problem right
yeah and then can talk about how great
it is how it doesn't hurt you how some
right tools of the job right and
how how how much how much better it
makes them feel wimp it's women talk
about it as hey you know you give this
to your men
and it makes them so much better it
makes you like it more and you know so
yeah sure we leave it up to them to kind
of put their own spin on it
gotcha okay you know we're almost out of
time so I just want to ask a couple more
questions you know the business has
changed dramatically since you went from
that serious advertising and it was you
and Ryan sort of refreshing YouTube to
today you know you're sponsoring four
other NFL teams and NASCAR teams and
that's pretty amazing where is it like
what is your goal with a business I
think that like you know do you want to
work here for 20 years
is there an exit strategy in the net
like you know within five years or like
what it look where do you want to go
with the business you know this is like
the business that you've created is
right in the wheelhouse of a lot of CPG
companies right it's almost like like
there's a lot of competition for the
Gillette's of the world from the Harry's
and Dollar Shave Club so the world this
is going up this is like in the same
industry but going after a very
different type of category or niche and
you're uniquely positioned and so sort
of one of the few companies in that
space what do you want to do and the way
that we think about that is we know if
we never like they never create or build
a business for the sole purpose of
exiting with with that in mind I just
feel like if you if you create a
successful business that transcends you
know fads or you know that can be
multi-generational that's a potentially
multi multi generational then then you
know be potential acquirers just come
it's natural so that's kind of how we
kind of how we think about it this build
a really successful business and so when
we when you look at back at in the last
4050 years
there aren't many brands that are able
to be multi-generation multi
irrational right I mean you look at like
head and shoulders they've sure
generations upon generations right
gillette generations upon generations
Pantene there aren't that many brains
are able to actually do that you've
mentioned all Procter & Gamble brands
they're gonna love that but there
there's there's there's not that many
that actually have the unit economics to
be able to to transcend what I mean by
that is it's it costs a lot of money it
costs a lot of money to build a brand it
is really expensive to build a brand and
if you are trying to sell a shampoo in
which you know at retail and you're
trying to build a business that way
there's nowhere you have enough margin
to actually build a brand right because
you don't want to take 20 35 20 30 years
to build a brand right sure you what you
want to be able to spend 50 million
dollars on marketing right or and then
grow that to a hundred million dollars
on marketing for five years six years
right and really have a global brand and
then and then then you start harvesting
I mean that's that's that's kind of how
we see it right you have to spend the
money upfront you have to you have to
pay your dues right and and build that
brand I really understand your audience
Bill create amazing products within
those five to six seven years and then
after that we can smoothly start
harvesting so that's kind of how we see
building a brand we we believe that with
our you tour unit economics because I
mean this we recoup the clock on the
first time sale so beyond anything else
many your portal on first unit sale
profit of first unit sale
so what able to recycle that cash very
very quickly so that's how we've been
able to scale so quickly without any
institutional funding right so I I think
there's not that many companies are able
to do that and there's virtually no
companies that are able to do that
especially that like you know there's
companies that are able to do that today
get to four or five million dollars in
revenue virtually no companies are able
to do that at the at 50 million dollars
in revenue that's why the aways and all
birds of the world have raised capital
yeah yeah we're we're very fortunate
that we you know we're able to get you
know beyond nine figures and yeah in in
revenue without institutional capital
and and you know to have that kind of
unit economic so that allows us so we
believe that that really helps us you
know be multi-generational looking a
grow this thing we're launching
internationally so we were early in
Australia Canada UK OB all of Europe you
know and within the next three to five
years be a truly global brand and then
it's you know it's all for harvesting
but what's really interesting beyond
that is the way we think about is we're
clearly incremental voice you know
there's there's no portfolio company in
growing care I would pry the last
frontier in male grooming agreed yeah
it's it's really amazing when like it's
not like you're competing with Gillette
you're in the same category and we're a
P&G and a quarter of manscaped you would
sit within their grooming category
likely but like it's not like you're
cannibalizing Gillette sales exactly
you know we anything we can we can help
it right we're went to the incremental
to the top-line revenue right and if you
look at men's men's hygiene in general
it's definitely growing but it's not
growing as fast as our category yeah
yeah and that not only is it growing
like I mean your category is primarily
growing because of you I think that like
you know people rarely realize that like
when native launch into target we grew
their deodorant category something like
8 percent or 10 percent the first year
and rarely do like you know target
hasn't seen that in a really long time
the men's you know below the waist
grooming category isn't growing quickly
and you're riding those coattails you're
the reason that it's growing quickly
you know we're seeing racism low data
with with target also great partner
great to be working with them there
yeah I'm loved target they just they're
just phenomenal partners but we're
seeing very similar things with them
this is
category hasn't been innovated and it's
a brand new category you know and you
got lucky with the name manscape that we
define in the category yeah yeah
fantastic name okay one last question
because I I put on Twitter I said you
know I was interviewing you for a
podcast what should I ask you and
someone from your own team actually
asked me to ask you this and they said
have Hulk guess how many gallons of boba
tea the manscape team has consumed in
total I guess so the reason behind this
is my my wife loves boba she just she's
addicted to boba so she got the entire
company addicted to boba so I would say
many many many hundreds of gallons of Bo
well okay if you have to give give me a
number
because I'm the tweeted this guy and be
like hey is this right or wrong I would
say cuz we ordered over almost every day
I gotta be like a hundred and twenty
gallons okay
no you're it's definitely more than 120
gals it's your boba everyday that's
right like 18 ounces there's 70 people
on the team probably 40 of them are
getting boba no it's gonna be that is
it's a great it's a great like line item
to have in a budget when you're like
doing a P&L and sort of showing it to
your board you're like that's how much
we're going to spend on boba this Paul
this was fantastic really love you know
that I really love what you've this
conversation I think you've you know
aside from one of the things that I've
realized about you is that aside from
having this incredible vision for the
company and sort of understanding where
you fit within the CPG space you also
have these humble origins and you have
like the perspective you you still
remember the perspective you had when
you launched the business and we're
struggling trying to get that right
messaging out trying to understand you
know how to get production up and like
understand what entrepreneurs are going
through when there's still much smaller
businesses I feel like very few people
have that perspective and it's so
refreshing to hear because I think that
a lot of people who were building to
three million four or who are at a two
three four million dollar run rate you
know don't necessarily want to talk
about
stuff that I brought up which was like
how do you think about budget you go
back and you're like look budget is what
we think about today the first two years
we called audibles of the line every
time we went up there and that was
really great I love how you mentioned
that because it makes me realize that
sometimes I've forgotten what it was
like to be in the trenches and makes me
miss those days so appreciate you sort
of bringing that up and having that like
you know in the trenches type of
mentality that was fantastic oh thank
you I really appreciate that I think
deep down at heart I'm an entrepreneur
and I'll always be an entrepreneur you
know we I think it's it's a it's a
special breed and I I celebrate all
entrepreneurs out there because it it
takes guts you know to go out there and
to sacrifice every single day to follow
your dreams it's not easy couldn't agree
more with that takes a ton of guts you
know you got to stand up to your family
and your friends who are you know and
are certainly at my age are like you
know lawyers and are making a lot of
money and had families you're like you
know what I'm gonna put everything on
the line so have a ton of respect for
those entrepreneurs and have a ton of
respect to the business at you too no
thank you
okay thanks so much Paul this was
fantastic really appreciate your time
congratulations on all the success super
excited you know after all this I also
makes me realize how excited I am as an
investor and manscaped I feel like when
you said all this I'm like Oh fantastic
man that's what it's doing really well
so thanks again for all the time and for
taking my money really appreciate that
thank you I'm excited to see what your
your next projects gonna be me too
I don't know what it'll be hopefully
once this Kovach stuff dies down I'll
think of something really appreciate it
[Music]